having it was a mommy's bread and I'm my
mom came to visit me out in Los Angeles
and my mom's real religious right I love
my mom but she was sitting at this
really fancy fancy hotel and she said
Maria the ritz-carlton is the kind of
hotel that Jesus would run if Jesus ran
a hotel
so mom what cut what kind of comedian
would Jesus be if Jesus were like a
comedian oh wow is that kid with the red
hair carrot top because he uses a lot of
props and his act and Jesus used a lot
of symbolism in this message so mom what
kind of scary green sea creature of the
deep would Jesus be if Jesus were like a
scary green sea creature of them
okay I'm not gonna answer that now
you're making fun of me come on but I
love my mom I used to be a secretary and
um I love that love the excitement I was
I was a temp never go perm lover every
day I'd wake up I didn't know if I was
gonna go file in a bank you never file
in an office or filing a bank office
it's hard it's hard for ladies now when
I was growing up in the eighties you
know you just had to be skinny right no
it's like the 90s we got all empowered
to get a muscle tone so it's like I'm
all tired and hungry but I gotta go work
out I think pretty soon is be kind of
almost impossible like you're gonna have
to be ginormously obese while
maintaining
a driver in Los Angeles lat
bless my car sounds like and um seems
like every stoplight there's always some
homeless guy stand-in there nice
thoughts go through my head like I could
give that guy 50 bucks that wouldn't
kill me I could ID him a personal check
he could probably cash that write a
first little check he but I take that
$50 buy crate because that's how much
credit cost I saw that once on Dateline
NBC
you take that $50 and get some hotel
room get himself all cleaned up use some
social service agency get job training
work his way up become an office manager
hire me ask me out ask me out I say yes
because he's really nice eyes even
though the kind of days dehydrated right
now then we fall in love and we get
married
Oh green light
[Music]
I'll get the song um if you know a song
joining um oh McDonald had it aired
actor
yeah yeah thank you very much
[Applause]